casimir à bonjour pierre etienne je
voudrais courir tu peux garder la balle
en jeu bien sûr je suis là pour ça donne
là moi je veux bien l'arranger un bon on
veut pouvoir ranger cette jolie balle
pour la retrouver facilement quand il
reviendra là ya pas de place
je vais la mettre là voilà casimir
qu'est ce que tu fais avec ton stands de
la fête
mon dieu ne fait plus lire aux excuses -
excuses - casimir gardien d'objets un
oui ça veut dire que les enfants du
jardin qui veulent jouer peuvent te
confier leurs affaires à garder
qu'est-ce qui se passe attends je
t'écoute
on a peur rien de cacher ce que tu peux
être ben par moments kazemi a vraiment
ainsi que l'avait vu ta tête
mais la question idiote réponse ça va ça
va ça va pas cela dit malgré tes
plaisanterie stupide
ton idée de garder des objets est
vraiment excellente et qui en a beaucoup
déjà ah oui tous les casiers sont déjà
presque plein 2010 dont casimir canton
viendra-t-on réclamer un tu es sûr de
s'y retrouver
oh j'ai un système de classement
infaillible à bon ben alors je vais te
confier quelque chose moss et casimir à
votre service a confiance sécurité
organisation parfait casimir
je joue au football avec les enfants je
te confie mon trousseau de clés voilà
pas de problème
merci qui est maire à tout à l'heure
nouvelle pouvoir ranger ce trousseau de
clés bon là c'est déjà plein oh la la
ah je vais je vais le glisser là dedans
voilà
on va casimir c'est formidable toliver
de garder des objets tu peux mot prendre
quelques-uns mais bien sûr julie casimir
à votre service confiance sécurité
organisation extraordinaire et pif et
santoni dégénère je me demande comment
j'aurais fait à ce que je vienne chez ma
grand mère qui m'a offert quelques
petits cadeaux que je vais emporter chez
moi ce soir
mais en attendant je ne fais pas où les
mettre parce que le kiosque est trop
petit il est bourré de toute façon alors
je vais te donner une cuillère en bois
qu'au bien une paire de ciseaux et avaaz
il ne me plaît pas beaucoup mais je suis
sûr qu'ils enchanterait monsieur
discours il aurait plus de chance de
plaire aux facteurs je crois que tu as
raison il faut que j'aille aux cascades
problème fait attention à tout je kazmir
confiance sécurité organisation
[Musique]
vous avez bien joué
pas trop mal mais moi je suis épuisée y
avait des champions dans les deux
équipes
eh bien casimir voilà 15 coste rails
mais pourquoi ce que vous venez tous
ensemble d'un coût de casimir qui sort
toutes les affaires chacun trop les
siennes
et voilà ah non je ne peux pas il ya des
objets qui ne sont pas un fou aude
écoute chacun france qui lui appartient
tout laisse le reste
non impossible si vous vous trompez on
m'accusera vous les avoirs volés
aucun du mur personne ne pense à des
choses pareilles de l'île aux enfants
ça ne fait rien je ne peux pas vous
montrer mais notre nous les objets qui
nous appartiennent ben c'est quand bon
là je crois que j'ai un peu tout
mélanger casimir à votre service
confiance sécurité organisation c'est
malin que se moquer des plus faibles
agents pas calmez-vous et cherchons
plutôt une solution
je crois que j'ai une idée aïe casimir
qui va nous faire entendre le bruit de
chaque objet quand il tombe par terre et
nous devrons trouver ce qui nous
appartiennent
après que les autres d'ailleurs très
bonne idée battus voire quand tu vois tu
n'es pas si bête
merci casimir vous nous aidez les
enfants
alors pierre étienne toi tu avais confié
à casimir une balle de caoutchouc mois
casimir j'avais confié mon trousseau de
clés je les ai ben moi la cuillère de
bois ma paire de ciseaux et move alpha
oui oui oui et vous aussi chez vous et
vous cherchez et s'y est trouvé les
premiers allez casimir bon alors vous ne
regardez pas je vais tomber leurs
premiers objets sur la balle de ping
comme là-bas depuis bolloré tiennent la
parabolica par mois pas moins ses balles
de caoutchouc
voilà c'est bien la tienne et retient
lucian qui a trouvé tiers vire etienne
c'est à bâle allons je vais faire tomber
un autre objet physique et chimie
derrière moi fier de mon cuir du bois du
meilleur de moi c'est ça oui c'est de
ghislain de bois c'est à julie s'est
indûment la géline bon ensuite des
immigrants ne bougeait si les ciseaux
oui c'est ça mais qui joueront donc
c'est pas la clochette c'est les ciseaux
caroline et jean emmanuel retient les
six ont messi et autres choses que j'ai
mise alors un autre objet à ne faut pas
regarder il faut pas tricher a touché ma
roue
c'était bien ça c'est les aléas père ça
sent bon
semag ac larmes en apporter tout à
l'heure je crois qu elle lui met de côté
ensuite casimir encore un objet
fricheteau de pimco sont forts et
casimir ans qui sont très pauvres
poursuit heureusement ils trouvent tout
de suite c'était c'est un monsieur du
snob
or où l'alarmé la lune comité voilà
encore un objet on regarde partage
nous attend car l'hymne est ce que c'est
une boîte de conserve une boîte de
conserve au travail et eric oui c'est
une boîte de complaire au crb elle est
offerte à moi elle était triste
ah oui bon d'accord et après aux
nombreux objets à la base à ce qu'est ce
que c'est que le nom et ben oui c'est
mou vase oui enfin c'est un combat passe
il ne reste plus que des morceaux
heureusement qui me plaisait pas fort
j'écoute julie si tu veux je reviens ce
temps balaie les morceaux non c'est pas
la peine
merci non bon alors encore un objet ce
que gémir quand même cette fois c'est
pour moi ça a payé
c'est pourquoi c'est pour moi donne mon
baptême à mes clés le voilà merci et
casimir didot sont pas mes clients ce
n'est pas le point à ben non c'est pas
moi ça j'en suis certain ah ben oui ça y
est je me souviens oui pour ne pas
perdre le tiens oui je l'avais bien
rangé je l'avais glisser dans ce bocal
qu'est ce que c'est que ce que immédiat
mais dans quoi tu me mets clé casimir
fait voir à oui c'est de la colle de la
colle pour que j'y mets
[Musique]